l'économie mondiale sévèrement touché
par l'épidémie et de coronavirus après
l'europe c'est l'économie américaine la
première au monde qui inquiète
en france l'insee a tenté de chiffrer
l'impact économique du confinement et il
s'annonce historiquement élevé cette
crise présenté comme la pire depuis 1945
risque-t-elle de provoquer une nouvelle
dépression eh bien on voit cela tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
avec nous par skype confinement oblige à
bienvenue jacques
merci olivier alors jacques pourquoi de
nombreux économistes parle-t-il du
risque d'une dépression aujourd'hui y
compris en france
mais olivier l'économie française est en
train de s'arrêter avec le confinement
de nombreuses activités ne peuvent en
effet se passer au télétravail et se
faire de manière décentralisée le risque
d'une faillite d'ailleurs se précise
pour de nombreuses pme et pas seulement
nous avons appris aujourd'hui que le
chausseur andré s'était mis en cessation
de paiement et donc ce rite va être
d'autant plus grand que la durée du
confinement va s'allonger
alors comme vous l'avez dit l'insee a
publié les premières prévisions à ces
dernières ne sont pas bonnes elles sont
d'ailleurs très probablement encore trop
optimiste il faut donc s'attendre à ce
que le coronavirus pousse l'économie
française ainsi que d'autres économies
dans le monde dans la dépression alors
jacques est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un petit peu plus sur les
prévisions de l'insee
oui tout à fait alors l'insee a fait une
première estimation de la baisse
d'activité de l'économie
elle l'estimé car je rappelle que ces
chiffres datent maintenant du 26 mars et
l'estimé à moins de 35 % du niveau
global d'activité seulement c'est un
véritable problème
cette estimation est certainement trop
optimiste par exemple sur l'agriculture
où il ya une baisse que de 4% et bien on
va constater très vite que l'agriculture
manque de main d'oeuvre saisonnière même
chose des services marchands et non
marchands
même quand le télétravail peut être
utilisés connaissent en réalité des
baisses de production plus importante
que les chiffres qui sont estimés par
l'insee alors du coup jacques calais
vous votre estimation
avec quelques collègues nous avons fait
nos estimations en utilisant d'ailleurs
les les données de l'insee
nous avons calculé la production
hebdomadaire de l'économie française
puis nous avons calculé cela en fonction
de l'impact du confinement
comme vous pouvez le voir la première
colonne donne le niveau de production
hebdomadaire pour 2019 la seconde
pourcentage estimé de baisse de la
production et voit qu on a été peut-être
plus sévère que l'insee et la troisième
la valeur est de madère de la production
une fois la fin du confinement et
comment cela serait partie t-il en
fonction du nombre de semaines de
confinement et bien regardons tout
d'abord ce que nous dit l'insee alors
lindsay n'a pas calculé par semaine mais
a calculé par mois et on voit ici que
pour un mois la baisse globale sur
l'année 2020 serait de 3% la baisse
globale pour deux mois serait 2 6%
ce sont les chiffres qui sont donnés par
l'insee mais sur ce point vous vous
diverger aussi jacques oui parce que
nous avons considéré que le confine ont
duré tout d'abord entre 6 et 8 semaines
et nous allons surtout considéré que le
retour à la normale ne seraient pas
automatiques ainsi que le suppose
l'insee nouveau - gagne plus dans nous
donner ces différents aspects et nous
l'avons fait y compris pour les données
de l'insee
alors on voit là que ça pousse les
données de l'insee à 8% pour huit
semaines mais que dont nous donner nous
arrivons à -10%
nous avons aussi une troisième hypothèse
qui combine un petit peu l'hypothèse de
l'insee est la nôtre et qui suppose par
exemple que dans les deux premières
semaines
eh bien on pourrait avoir des niveaux de
production qui serait proche de ce que
l'insee a prévu mais qu'après pour la
troisième quatrième et cinquième semaine
et bien l'économie se calmer
progressivement sur notre scénario et on
voit là que l'on arrive à une baisse de
production pour l'année 2020 je le
répète 29.7 pour ça mais du coup jacques
ce sont des baisses considérables
oui absolument olivier sont des baisses
tout à fait considérable le choc sur la
production et le pire que la france ait
connue depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
depuis 1945
l'impact sur les pme peut être absolue
dévastateur des grandes entreprises sont
elles mieux protégés par le système de
chômage partiel qui touche désormais
quatre millions de personnes
mais si le gouvernement tarde à soutenir
les pme et les tpe qui n'ont plus de
rentrées d'argent il faut le dire
eh bien nous pourrions avoir entre eux
ça cent mille et un million de chômeurs
de plus à la fin de cette année et quel
en sera l'impact sur les finances
publiques
sonné il faut bien dire que l'impact
sera lourd est là aussi nous avons
utilisé les chiffres de l'insee puis
nous avons utilisé nos propres
estimations et on voit que le fardeau ça
pourrait être un déficit budgétaire
allant de -10 % pour le calcul de six
semaines de l'insee jusqu à -11% pour
huit semaines
d'après les calculs que nous avons fait
alors que peut-il se passer
et bien bonne question
on a plusieurs on a plusieurs
hypothèques ce alors trois sources de
financement ont été évoqués tout d'abord
les fameux corona bon les banquiers
seraient émis uniquement 1 par rapport à
cette épidémie et dont on sait qu'ils
ont été refusé d'emblée par l'allemagne
et par les pays bas et puis nous avons
la mobilisation du mécanisme européen de
stabilité mes là les italiens et les
français d'ailleurs exige qu'il se fasse
sans condition ceux qui refusaient par
l'allemagne donc exit aussi cette
possibilité reste ce qu'a fait la banque
centrale européenne ce qu'on appelle le
pandémique emergency purchasing
programme
et qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui va en
résulter et bien tout simplement que la
banque centrale européenne va se mettre
à acheter massivement de la dette des
différents pays de la zone euro
on est aujourd'hui devant une situation
qui devient de plus en plus compliqué
vous voyez que le confinement plus il
durera plus il provoquera une dépression
sévère de l'économie et on voit aussi
que de la politique du gouvernement de
sa capacité à réagir dépendra énormément
le fait que cette dépression ne soit que
transitoire ce qu'il faut espérer ou
qu'elles se prolongent
malheureusement au delà de l'épidémie
merci beaucoup jacques pour ses
explications très éclairant 20 sur les
implications économiques de cette crise
sans précédent bon courage dans votre
confinement à très bientôt sur rt france